capcom may have expressed interest in  nintendo switch but it doesn't sound  like resident evil will be arriving on  the console at any point in the near  future producer masa chica Khawaja told  express online I'm looking forward to  the possibilities of the system itself  but we have no plans at the moment and  regarding resident evil on switch Capcom  is counted among the dozens of  development partners for the switch so  it's highly likely will see Capcom games  arrive on the console at some point  resident evil 7 launches on january 24  for ps4 xbox one and pc it was also  recently confirmed as an Xbox play  anywhere game for Xbox one and PC be  sure to stay tuned to gamespot for all  the new games that are arriving on  switch and all the other things that are  going on in gaming